Marcus do I have to pick up from that
whole area that I flubbed yes so the
weird thing yes huh no I thank you I can
hear the speaker system thank you for
having faith in me people and you guys
have to pretend like you've never heard
it before
dude that fuck something else up before
that Hey
how dare you brazen of course you
fucking notice that I didn't want to put
a ring on her cuz I was too afraid it
was gonna fall off and of course she's
like where's the Reid she's not engaged
I'm engaged
I fucking worked for it she didn't do
shit ok so I think we're gonna do some
pickups I know that I have to pick up
the end of that because I fucked it up I
don't know if you guys notice I
stuttered through it no what do you guys
know about comedy I think I would know
if I fuck job no I did like stutter
trust me and then in the very beginning
I think I had a like thing happen to my
throat cuz I panicked you guys were like
we haven't been listening this entire
time it's like what are you talking
about huh no no I she goes normal nerves
I'm human I don't want I'm not going for
human what a nightmare
have you seen humans recently that's not
really something to aspire to have
you've seen the news that's why I want
this bitch to replace me she doesn't get
nervous
she doesn't fucking sweaty there Jesus
so basically she just needs to say like
now streaming on Netflix just stuff like
that right Marcus I don't know I'm not I
don't watch these things what did they
say
what did you say what oh just look who's
so savvy it's actually a very good idea
you're right we shot it so can we just
have her say now my special is now
streaming on Netflix is that what
happens normally I don't know you guys
watch it right what's that
she goes we don't watch commercials
three mean on Netflix you're a monster